- [Instructor] Have you ever tried
to hold a staring contest with a rock?
If you did, you might not have
expected that all that time
you were staring at one of the sneakiest
shape-shifters in the world.
No, rocks don't shapeshift into unicorns,
but they do change shape and composition.
Sometimes they change quickly,
like when an interrupting volcano
launches molten rock into the air.
And sometimes they change slowly,
like when a rock is heated and compressed
in the earth for thousands
to millions of years.
When geologists stare at a rock,
they can figure out the rocks composition
and tell the story of how it was created.
And it turns out rocks can be
made in many different ways.
When put it the right
combination of heat and pressure,
rocks can become molten and liquid.
When this molten rock
cools and becomes solid,
we call the rock it makes igneous rock.
This term comes from
the Latin word igneus,
which means fiery or burning hot.
Igneous rocks make up more
than 90% of the Earth's crust.
One common kind of
igneous rock is granite,
which you've probably seen in bridges,
buildings, and countertops.
Another kind of igneous rock is obsidian,
which is smooth and glassy,
and is sometimes used
to make knife weights.
Both of these rocks were
made of molten rock.
So why do they look so different?
Well, granite was made from magma,
which is molten rock that exists
below the surface of the earth.
Magma tends to cool slowly underground,
which gives time for the elements in it
to form large crystals.
And this obsidian rock was made from lava,
which is molten rock that
flows above the ground.
Lava tends to cool quickly,
which causes the rocks
it forms like obsidian,
tuff smaller crystals.
I always remember the difference
between magma and lava like this.
I keep my lava lamp above the ground,
just like lava is above the ground.
If I buried my lava lamp in the ground,
then I can call it a magma lamp.
Once an igneous rock is
created, its journey isn't over.
The rock might begin to change
through a process called weathering.
This is when water, weather,
wind, and other physical forces
chip away at a rock
and cause little pieces to break off.
These little particles
are called sediments.
The sediment from our igneous rock
can be moved around by wind and water.
This is called erosion.
Eventually, the sediment
will settle down somewhere.
Maybe at the bottom of an ocean or a lake,
and it might join other
sediment from other rocks,
crushed up shells, and plant matter.
And over time, this
sediment will become a rock.
Rocks that are formed from sediments
are called, you guessed
it, sedimentary rocks.
But how does sedimentary goop
at the bottom of the lake become a rock?
Well, it goes through a
process called lithification.
Lith comes from the Greek word for stone.
So you can think of this
process as stonification.
The first step of lithification
is called deposition.
This is when sediment is
deposited in a new location
and it spreads out to form a layer.
As more and more layers are created,
the layers underneath them
become squished together.
This is called compaction.
When water moves to
the layers of sediment,
it can carry dissolve minerals with it.
The water can leave these minerals
in between the sediment particles,
which makes everything stick together.
This cementing of sediment
is called cementation.
Limestone is a sedimentary
rock that is made with sediment
that contains a lot of
calcium carbonate in it
goes through lithification.
But once the sedimentary
rock has been created,
it doesn't mean that it is done changing.
Sometimes a rock is
squeezed or heated so much
that the minerals inside it
actually change composition.
It is now a metamorphic rock.
You might've heard of
the word metamorphosis,
which describes when something changes
from one form and structure to another.
Like when a caterpillar
turns into a butterfly.
Metamorphic rocks are made
when igneous, sedimentary,
or even other metamorphic rocks
change form and structure
because of heat and pressure.
For example, when the
sedimentary rock, limestone,
gets put under a lot of heat and pressure,
it can turn into marble,
but metamorphic rocks still
may not be done changing.
Rocks can actually keep
on changing forever.
Igneous and metamorphic rocks
can become sedimentary rocks
if they're broken apart into sediments
and go through lithification.
And metamorphic rocks
and sedimentary rocks
can become igneous rocks
when they are melted
and then cools.
And igneous rocks and sedimentary rocks
can become metamorphic rocks
when they're exposed to
high heat and pressure.
This is called the rock cycle.
So maybe next time you get
the chance to stare at a rock.
See if you can figure
out whether it's igneous,
metamorphic, or sedimentary.
And when rocks changed so much,
who knows what kind of rock it'll be next.